hey this is pressure Walker I received
this Mathcounts problem by email from
bill find all positive integers n for
which n squared plus 45 is a perfect
square
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution
suppose N squared plus 45 equals a
perfect square x squared we now subtract
N squared from both sides of the
equation to get 45 equals x squared
minus N squared we now can perform a
little trick we have the difference of
two squares and we can factor that as
the product of x plus n and X minus n so
we're looking for two factors of 45 the
possibilities for this can be 45 times
115 times 3 and 9 times 5 we now need to
set the equations equal to these factors
since X plus n is larger than X minus n
we will set X plus n equal to the larger
factor this is because x and n are
positive integers so from the first
possibility we set X plus n to equal 45
and X minus n to equal 1 in the next
possibility we have X plus N equals 15
and X minus N equals 3 we then have X
plus N equals 9 and X minus N equals 5
we can solve each of these equations for
X and n in the first set of equations
for example we can add up the two
equations to get that 2x is equal to 46
and then we divide by 2 to get x is
equal to 23 we can then go back and
solve that n is equal to 22 we can use
the same trick for the next two
equations as well we end up with X is
equal to 9 and N equals 6 and then X is
equal to 7 and N equals 2 so you know
the three possibilities n can equal 22 6
and 2 and those are the only ways in
positive integers
that N squared plus 45 will be equal to
a perfect square did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions that you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Walker and if you like this video please
check out my books there are links in
the video description